una ley aprobada por unanimidad los
diputados de la duma a la cámara baja
del parlamento ruso votaron todos a
favor de la anexión de las regiones de
iTunes
ya ocupadas en parte o en su casi
totalidad por músculo una ley que según
el jefe de la diplomacia rusa protegería
la cultura y las fronteras de su país
Quiero unirme a este ambiente festivo y
felicitar al representantes de estas
cuatro regiones de la federación rusa
no estamos reaccionando ante amenazas
imaginarias en países lejanos
estamos defendiendo nuestras fronteras
nuestra patria
nuestro pueblo de un verdadero genocidio
organizado por los Sucesores de los
acólitos nazis al servicio de Los Amos
de ultramar
el ministro de asuntos exteriores acusó
a Estados Unidos de haber según sus
palabras sometido a occidente y
utilizará Ucrania como un instrumento de
guerra contra Moscú Y es que la mayoría
de las potencias o sigue condenando la
anexión de estas cuatro regiones
[Música]
la fuerza de los referendos amañados
demuestra que Rusia se da cuenta de su
fragilidad y busca dar un barniz
democrático a sus ofensivas
no reconoceremos estos supuestos
referendos ni La anexión ilegal de
Vladimir Putin Esto no es más que una
provocación
Rusia inició la semana pasada al proceso
formal de anexión con el presidente
Vladimir chiquito firmando la ley junto
a los líderes prorrusos de las cuatro
regiones pero ninguna está totalmente
bajo el control de sus fuerzas y Ucrania
ha ido avanzando en sus contraofensivas
en el sur y el este del país